bonjour bonjour
Maïté aujourd'hui de la cuisine
familiale la cuisine traditionnelle
et facile qu'avez-vous l'intention de
nous faire et bien aujourd'hui on va
faire en rôti de beurre à la ficelle et
vous voulez le faire cuire comme une
bécasse dans la cheminée celui-là c'est
très original ce n'est jamais mangé du
bœuf à la ficelle et bien vous allez
voir et puis il y a une seconde recette
on va faire des aubergines au parmesan
alors pour ces deux recettes que vous
faut-il mais il faut des carottes il
faut des petits poireaux au fond du
poireau il faut du salarié il faut des
tomates des navets de l'oignon
évidemment des aubergines du thym et du
laurier il faut ça c'est inhabituel je
crois que c'est de l'origan merci je me
rappelle plus parce que dans les airs
vraiment assez bien mais parmesan bien
entendu de l'ail et une échalote oui
aussi et puis le rôti alors un très joli
petit filet de bœuf bien tendre et pour
commencer qu'est-ce qu'il faudra faire
et bien on va faire le bouillon
avec quels légumes un bouillon
dans la marmite voilà alors je vais
d'abord mettre du sel du gros sel du
gros sel et salé et poivrée mon bouillon
bien entendu je vais y mettre le bouquet
garni
bien sûr je vais y mettre laurier persil
mettre un oignon avec trois clous de
girofle piqué à l'intérieur
ensuite je vais y mettre la branche de
céleri
le poireau que je vais raccourcir un
petit peu qui est trop gros
voilà un de plus ah oui T3 oui
là
après nous allons y en avait
que je vais couper un cadre pour qu'il
donne bon goût des carottes
bien entendu c'est toujours pareil
c'est une espèce qui ne se défait pas
même dans les longues cuissons
un petit peu d'ail les pommes de terre
on va les mettre et après vous allez
voir ce qu'on va faire alors là je
laisse à découvrir normalement on laisse
bien cuire oui comme si on faisait un
fumet ou quelque chose on fait en somme
un liquide parfumé dans lequel on va
cuire la viande alors ici bien joli un
rôti de bœuf oui même vous avez une très
très jolie viande là je crois que c'est
un filet ça c'est un filet de bœuf c'est
délicieux c'est diverses
alors on met voilà
et dans ce petit bruit on va y mettre
cette cuillère
que je vais faire passer là dedans oui
voilà
et là
c'est une espèce de branche de branche
voilà regardez ça là et on va mettre
ce rôti comme ceci c'est presque à l'eau
froide puisque
il est sorti
c'est ça qui est important et on va la
laisser cuire là alors là il faut se
réveiller le cuisse de temps de cuisson
on peut pas le dire la différence avec
un pot-au-feu
c'est peut-être que vous avez pas le
cuir autant bon le pot-au-feu vous le
mettez deux heures à 3h
tandis que là il faut surveiller parce
que là-bas il est long et merci donc il
faut à peu près 20 minutes puis il est
pas saisi comme dans un four là oui mais
vous voulez qu'il soit saignant
alors donc il faut le surveiller et donc
ça sera je ne sais pas
moi j'ai dit 20 minutes et ça ira alors
on va l'attendre et ensuite
c'est qu'on aura un bouillon très
parfumé
longtemps on a mis les pommes de terre
donc on a le légume on a le bouillon on
a la viande avec tous les légumes alors
regardez c'est fait on a une seule
opération il ne manque plus que le
fromage de dessert qu'on ne peut pas y
mettre dedans alors un tout petit peu de
patience et pendant ce temps on peut
peut-être préparer pour le repas du soir
par exemple pour l'autre repas le gratin
d'aubergines au parmesan voilà vous les
coupez comment aromate je laisse la peau
voilà
un bon centimètre
là on va les mettre dans la le saladier
qui est à côté de vous
je vais vous le donner
il faut leur faire quelque chose dans ce
saladier avant de les cuire
oui parce que l'aubergine ça a beaucoup
d'eau comme le concombre
alors je vais y mettre du gros sel
quand même malheureusement là non
voilà il faudra à peu près un quart
d'heure il faut les attendre mais on
peut faire autre chose alors c'est nous
quoi et nous on va faire la tomate alors
vous commencez par quoi classiquement un
peu d'huile dans la poêle et un peu
d'oignon probablement
la tomate bien améliorée un petit peu
quand même une
comme qu'on peut directement à tout le
monde sait faire on peut penser quand
même une base de sauce tomate ça serait
gravé
là voilà et on met toujours l'oignon en
premier parce que c'est le plus loin
et c'est vrai
et ça va faire bon comme ça
je vais y rajouter un peu d'ail ou pas
encore
tout de suite
et maintenant pas là il brûlerait les
tomates
qui me sont toutes pelés
ce qui est bien agréable pour les
pellets on les trompe on les trompe un
instant dans l'eau bouillante c'est pas
compliqué ça
et cela tomate ça va être délicieux
parce que tomate pêche comme ça c'est
très bon dans l'hiver on ajoute ce qu'il
faut pour la relever un petit peu voilà
après je vais mettre l'ail la dernière
encore voilà très bien vous les salez
encore un petit peu
et je vais y mettre maintenant
du poivre du poivre assez et oui
voilà et on va laisser cuire ça
tranquille
juste une gousse
alors là vous comptez à peu près combien
de temps faut bien 20 minutes pendant
que la sauce réduit qu'est-ce que vous
faites Maïté
là je mets deux œufs dans une assiette
dans l'autre j'ai mis de la farine
tout simplement c'est facile et c'est
classique
voilà et ensuite alors
je prends mes aubergines on enlève un
petit peu le sel je les trempe dans la
farine d'abord et hop dans le Far près
dans la fabrique et qu'est-ce qu'on fait
on ouvre les préparer comme ça d'abord
regardez ça là
je vous la retourne dans l’œuf
des deux côtés
je vous en fais vite une ou deux plus
il y a la place ça va très vite voilà
c'est bon
c'est bien et ça y est
il entretien
c'est bon le rôti est-ce qu'il est temps
de le sortir
je vous prépare une assiette pour le
mettre et voilà on va sauf que vous
croyez qui va être saignant comme il
faudrait là
montrez-nous ça maintenant et puis on va
le couper
mais oui il va être comme il faut
regarder qui aurait cru ça quand je suis
contente je ne l'avais jamais essayé le
bœuf à la ficelle mais c'est formidable
il est magnifique
à peu près 20 minutes ça a pris et là on
va y mettre maintenant nos légumes
quelques petits légumes et voilà un plat
absolument délicieux
c'est joli comme tout quand on vous dit
que c'est un repas complet débris ou
c'est pas vrai
pas besoin de salir le four on fait tout
dans la marmite c'est quand même un truc
à se rappeler ça et voilà la pomme de
terre qui ne fait pas des fêtes ça y est
c'est tout prêt alors Maïté maintenant
qu'est-ce qui vous reste à faire
retourner les aubergines et préparer le
gratin vous avez tapissé Maïté un plat
qui va au four avec une première couche
d'aubergine et c'est joli et maintenant
je vais y mettre ma tomate bien réduite
bien réduite elle est jolie là voilà
alors je vous la mettre toute parce que
quand même ça va bien s'imprégner tout
le
toutes les deux couches
là regardez-moi ça bon
mais ça on va remettre
donc aux aubergines parfaites
elles sont bien dorées des deux côtés
elles vont finir de cuire dans le gratin
vous avez mis le four à chauffer bien
entendu très fort
là regardez ça ça tombe juste
c'est merveilleux alors on va mettre un
petit peu de parmesan un peu beau c'est
vrai
ne soyez parade dingue
un grand soupçon et on va faire on va
mettre ça au four
juste le temps de gratiner
ma famille minimum 15 minutes maximum 40
minutes vous le mettez au four mais bien
évidemment
et voilà tout simplement il y a plus
qu'à présenter les plats maintenant
le bœuf à la ficelle bien saignant comme
il doit être et curieusement c'est une
recette très traditionnelle et très
ancienne mais oubliez souvent maintenant
peut-être oublié mais regardez le
résultat comme il est beau et oui vous
faites souvent chez vous comme ça
on le fera par contre le gratin
d'aubergines
vous en ferez dimanche prochain pour la
famille c'est vrai et vous vous ferez
dimanche prochain pour la famille le
bœuf à la ficelle le gratin d'aubergine
vous ne risquez rien du tout à bientôt
bon appétit à bientôt
[Musique]